hey guys welcome back to a brand-new
Verbeck I'm for endurance today we're
gonna be talking about how to get
unlimited champion status in for honor
so as always like the V if you do enjoy
subscribe before new I cover the
informational side of honor that'd be
news updates hero changes balance
changes patch notes all that stuff as
well as giving tips and tricks and
making funny videos as well on my spare
time and that sounds interesting then
consider subscribing let's get on with
today's topic so as I said today we're
gonna be talking about how to get
unlimited champion status the main
reason you would want champion says is
to either get extra loot for more
Salvage or customization maybe get more
steel or rank up a hero
and with the new Wulin faction coming
and entering the game on October 16th
people will definitely want to get their
gear as soon as possible now a lot of
people always ask me the question how I
get so much steel and it's mostly
because I have nothing to spend it on
since I don't have a whole roster of
characters as my main I only use one
character and it's also because of this
method now a 69,000 steel isn't a lot of
steel but it's big to some players now
this isn't a glitch and the only things
you're going to be needing are some
extra steel and some time to play it
probably at least 10 minutes a day now
let me explain real quick where champion
status is if you're unfamiliar basically
it gives you more xp for matches more
loot and more Salvage but also giving
you a couple emblems for your shield
icon and some bonus xp for your
teammates as well so it's a pretty
useful tool like I said if you do want
to get more loot Salvage customization
ranking up a hero maybe more steel it
works in all those different departments
now to do this simply go to the champion
status tab in the store and go to the
one that says 7 days this costs 4000
steel but you can keep this up for more
than 7 days so let's head to the orders
tab to tell you why the first order I
have for me today is warrior but that
doesn't really matter we're only caring
about the steel the first daily every
single day gives you 300 steel and the
second will always give you 500 the day
these are usually really easy and could
take about 10 to 15 minutes depending on
what they are and that will give you 800
steel just for the dailies now if you
happen to hop on foreign or do the
dailies and then hop off then all you
would need to do is do the dailies five
out of the seven days to get the exact
number of steel you paid for which is
four thousand because 800 times five is
four thousand steel which is like I said
the exact number we spent on these seven
days of champion status if you happen to
do all seven days of the dailies then
you would get an extra 1600 steel left
as profit but that's also not count in
the contract
or the steel from the end of the matches
contract orders in foreign our refresh
every two days if I'm not mistaken and
they can range from matches played to
renounce score the heart of the
challenge the more steel you get and
received the lowest possible you could
receive is a hundred and the highest
being two hundred if I believe the only
reason these are so low compared to the
dailies is because that would be a
little bit overpowered and they didn't
want so many people having so much steel
and also these are more meant for XP and
not steel but they still help and that's
basically if you don't mind spending
some steel to get the same steel and a
little bit more back then this method is
perfect for you just to recap by these
seven days of Champions that is booster
then do five of the seven dailies to
either get it back or do all of them for
a sixteen hundreds to profit but that's
like I said before not counting the
contract orders of the steel counts or
the steel from the earned matches at the
end if you guys do find this video
helpful please be sure to leave a like
and subscribe for new like I said I
cover the informational side of honor
that being balance changes hero updates
new events new leaks new hero updates
all the new stuff and basically giving
you guys all the information to keep you
up to date on for honor and what's
happening in the game while also giving
you tips tricks and then funny meme
filled videos when I have the time on my
spare time and as always my two most
recent videos would be on screen if you
guys want to check that out when that
guys over very yesterday I take part in
the video and peace out
[Music]
[Music]